después de que lograste cruzar el puente
del gnomo y que lograste a salvar el
príncipe oa la princesa ustedes deciden
regresar el principio de la princesa con
su padre el rey y él está tan emocionado
de que regresaste con vida a su hijo o
hija que decide hacer un banquete en su
honor sin embargo está preocupado porque
él no se desperdicia el alimento así que
él quiere saber cuántos pastelillos van
a comprar cuántos pastelillos necesitan
ordenar él quiere estar seguro de que no
se quede con vida pero tampoco que los
invitados se queden con hambre es decir
que todos tengan suficiente que comer y
tú le contestas oye rey pero cuál es el
problema y él te va a responder el
problema es que los niños no comen igual
que los adultos lo que sí sé es que
todos los adultos como es lo mismo y
todos los niños comen lo mismo entonces
para quedar bien con el rey le dices voy
a intentar ayudarte en esta devastadora
situación déjame ver si puedo resolver
este problema y el rey te va a responder
pues mira en la última fiesta del reino
ok sem asistieron 500 adultos y 200
niños
y esa vez en total nos comimos 2900
pastelitos 2900 pastelillos y entonces
ya réplicas al rey bueno esta
información es bastante útil pero no
tendrás la información de otra fiesta
anterior a ésta en la que sepamos
también cuánto comieron un cierto número
de personas y él te va a decir si a
nosotros nos gusta hacer muchas fiestas
y en la fiesta pasada nos ocurrió lo
siguiente fueron 500 adultos y 300 niños
y en total entre todos nos comimos 3100
pastelillos cuando esta información te
es suficiente y tú le dirás pues voy a
intentarlo
así que lo primero que vamos a hacer es
preguntarnos qué es lo que queremos
saber y en este caso en ese problema lo
que estamos buscando es el número de
pastelillos que se comieron cada uno de
los adultos y el número de pastelillos
que se comió cada uno de los niños el
número de pastelillos que se comió por
adulto y el número de pastelillos que se
consumen por niño esto es lo que yo
quiero y bueno pues entonces sería muy
bueno que empezáramos a definir a
bautizar a cada uno
nuestras incógnitas voy a decir que
nuestra primer incógnita la voy a llamar
a así que déjame ponerlo aquí voy a
definir al número de panecillos que se
consume por adulto con la letra a y
bueno voy a decir que la otra que es la
cantidad de panecillos que se comen o
que consumen los niños lo voy a denotar
con la letra c a y c ya continuación lo
que hay que hacer es buscar la forma de
escribir esta información estos datos
que nos dio el rey en ecuaciones
matemáticas y si te das cuenta lo
primero que tengo son 500 adultos y 200
niños consumieron en total 2900
pastelillos qué quiere decir eso que si
lo escribimos en forma matemática voy a
tener que 500 adultos multiplicado por
la cantidad de pastelillos que consume
un adulto y después tengo 200 niños
multiplicado por la cantidad de
pastelillos que consume un niño
es decir 200 cm esto es igual a 2900 si
sumamos estas dos cantidades 500 am más
200 cm esto tiene que ser igual a 2900
pastelillos que es la información que me
dan y de igual manera podremos hacer
algo parecido para el segundo dato que
nos han pues la respuesta es que si de
hecho va a ser muy parecido
tenemos que 500 adultos y 300 niños
consumieron 3100 pastelillos y si esto
mismo yo lo escribo en lenguaje
matemático me va a quedar que 500 por la
cantidad de pastelillos que consume una
adulto es decir por am y después 300 por
la cantidad de pastelillos que consume
un niño es decir se y sumados estos dos
500 a más de cientos se tiene que ser
igual a 3100 pastelillos 3100 y es justo
en este momento donde nos emocionamos
porque nos damos cuenta que de igual
manera que en el acertijo del troll aquí
tenemos dos ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas y por lo tanto podemos
resolver este sistema sin embargo la vez
pasada resolvimos el sistema
gráficamente
se te ocurre que tal vez haya otras
formas de resolver este mismo sistema
utilizando el álgebra que ya conocemos
así que vamos a escribir la primera
ecuación que es 500 a más 200 cm y vamos
a buscar la forma algebraica de resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones y tengo 500
más 200 es igual a 2900 si te das cuenta
que tenemos una ecuación con dos
incógnitas estaría muy bien eliminar una
de estas dos incógnitas y para eso pues
vamos a restar 500 a para que se pueda
eliminar la información que tenemos de a
sin embargo no podemos restar 500 así de
la nada por lo tanto a ti se te ocurre
decir que si vamos a quitar 500 pues
estaría muy bien que también quitamos
300 cm de tal manera que utilicemos la
información que nos dan en la segunda
ecuación entonces como no podemos quitar
tienen sal de la nada voy a quitar
también 300 cm pero ojo como lo estoy
quitando de lado izquierda de la
ecuación tengo que hacer lo mismo del
lado derecho de la ecuación recuerda que
es como una balanza y lo que hacemos un
lado de la ecuación también hay que
hacerlo del otro lado de la ecuación
entonces voy a poner que aquí tengo 2900
pero entonces también de este lado del
lado derecho tengo que hacer lo mismo
quitar menos 500 a menos 300 cm y aquí
es cuando te das cuenta del problema que
sigues teniendo dos incógnitas sin
embargo ahorita vamos a utilizar toda la
información que nos dan así que del lado
derecho voy a poner menos 500 al menos
300 cm y te das cuenta que menos 500 a
menos 300 es exactamente lo mismo que
menos 3100 porque fíjate bien menos 500
menos que multiplica 500 a más 300 cm
pero 500 más 300 sé es lo mismo que 3100
eso es lo que tenemos aquí arriba por lo
tanto esto es lo mismo que menos 3100
así que en lugar de escribir en mi lado
derecho de la ecuación menos 500 o sea
menos 300 m dejamos seleccionarlo y en
lugar de esto voy a poner menos 3100 de
tal manera que pueda operarlo con este
2900 que tengo aquí arriba entonces voy
a poner que menos 500 al menos 300 cm es
exactamente igual que menos
es 1100 y a continuación se te ocurre
que lo que podemos hacer es sumar estas
dos ecuaciones para ver qué es lo que
obtengo y si sumamos estas dos
ecuaciones se va a poder cancelar el 500
a menos de 500 que es justo lo que
queremos así que vamos a hacerlo de este
lado 500 a menos 500 se cancelan por
otra parte tengo 200 menos 300 en lo
cual es menos 100 cm y del lado derecho
lo que a 2.900 menos 3100 lo cual es
menos 200 y que obtuvimos obtuvimos una
ecuación que tiene solamente una
incógnita y por lo tanto esta es muy
fácil de resolver si dividido todo entre
menos 100 me va a quedar que menos 100 y
menos 100 se va y me queda que se es
igual a menos 200 entre menos ciento lo
cual es 2 perfecto ya tengo el valor de
ce se vale 2 es decir que la cantidad de
pastelillos que consume cada uno de los
niños es 2 se es igual a 2 y ya tenemos
a una de nuestras incógnitas pero espera
todavía no hemos acabado una vez que ya
sabemos el valor de ese pues habrá que
saber cuál es la cantidad de pastel
que se come cada uno de los adultos y
para esto voy a utilizar la información
de que se es igual a 2 en alguna de mis
ecuaciones porque por ejemplo en la
primera ecuación yo sé que 500 a más 200
cm pero ojo ya sé cuánto vale cm se vale
entonces me va a quedar 500 a más 200
por 2 esto es exactamente igual a 2900 y
si te das cuenta de aquí ya vamos a
despejar me queda que 500 a más 400 200
por 12 400 es igual a 2900 y a
continuación detuviese de restar 400 de
ambos lados de la ecuación y que me
queda menos 400 aquí menos 400 sacamos y
vamos a hacer las operaciones de este
lado no queda 500 porque el 490 y 400 se
cancela y del lado derecho me queda 2900
menos 400 lo cual es dos mil quinientos
500 a es igual a 2.500 y ya con esto
casi tengo el valor de a si le pido
ambos lados la ecuación entre 500 me va
a quedar que am es igual a 2500 entre
500 lo cual es 5 y perfecto hay 5 y ya
con esto también sé
es la cantidad de pastelillos que come
cada uno de los adultos cada uno de los
adultos se come cinco pastelillos cada
adulto comerá cinco pastelillos mientras
que cada niño se comerá dos pastelillos
y entonces el rey te felicita porque has
podido resolver su duda existencial ya
podrá dormir tranquilo y además ya
podrás saber cuánta comida y cuántos
pastelillos pedir en el banquete que se
celebrará en tu honor